this video was brought to you by loot
crate doesn't work does it I'll tell you
what does work inflatables today's video
is all about inflatable what's
inflatable bread egos my ego is so
inflated that I need to fill it with
other items and that's what we're doing
here today on the pewdiepie channel
let's go
guess what the first item is that's why
you guess it Patera no don inflatable
again what is that sorry
Pteranodon cetera Dona Pteranodon
Patera Patera Pteranodon veteran veteran
node on parade Patera
the Pteranodon Pteranodon oh man this is
gonna take me so much effort to blow
this up the things I do for your Bryce
I'm exhausted
oh man so much effort Hey
collect them all go pizza Ranma John
whoa whoa dude that was [ __ ] awesome
it's a good patina and I thought they
were called petard Actos he knows he'll
put me under his wing any day that's
that's right
is that a good voice the [ __ ] did you
say by my mother shut the [ __ ] up I will
destroy
it's still alive
what to die
I don't know what it is we'll fill it
out with my ego and see what comes out
it's furry costume you got me a [ __ ]
furry costume what do you think I am
pyrocynical oh my god that's awesome
so I got marked yeah this is this is how
I got Martin yeah
and that lost like happier okay here we
go
here we go why I just realized why oh
it's for kids yeah no that was pretty
[ __ ] the next item is
oh it's hilarious that's funny it's a
walking frame whoa Dawg yo Dawg this
cool man
alright let's blow this [ __ ] up just
like your mother does yeah that's right
it's done now let's see this thing works
I fall in I'm dying
help me hey yeah you son of a [ __ ]
what is the one thing that we all want
that's right
oops inflatable boobs let's give it a go
one today
it's gonna video that if my child my
child will see if I walk in my kid is
watching this video I mean no hi guys
welcome to sniper wolves Channel you got
roasting
the next item is for cats I don't have a
cat but I have Edgar again okay you're
gonna look adorable all right just trust
me oh my god yes no don't look at me
don't look at me dog
this is how I kiss dogs okay so the next
item is party boy inflatable party boy I
probably bought five of these in my
lifetime which is five more than you
should never buy I mean love but that's
love at first sight right there look at
those orangie lips and blue eyes I'm not
even gonna blow this out because it's
gonna use too much of my ego I kind of
like him just as a skin suit you know is
it should I
so how are you guys doing Tom how are
you guys
what's that sponsor Eagle sponsor Eagle
this year ah thank you
alright let's you know what that means
ladies a little foreplay I look great I
love you you're the best like think
about we work with a lot of different
brands look gray that's not the only
ones that let us do what we want
check out lucre dad calm sighs kids
enter the code kids
oh oh I'm opening last month's theme
which is dystopian the theme changes
every month of the 19th so you gotta
order before then if you want the theme
next month's theme it's futuristic
the only way to find out about the
future is to order in the present oh
it's exciting it's a good package god
damn I was so neatly packed a t-shirt
holy [ __ ] this is a cool one I like the
Sun it's Robocop we'd like a Japanese
style no it's not that was racist I mean
why is there a Sun behind it is it
really [ __ ] cool I like it that's
really cool we have a matrix puzzle
because the matrix is a puzzling series
of movies trilogy it has 300 puzzle
pieces you have to be 17 plus 2y what
tech [ __ ] is in this puzzle I had never
seen that before
I wanna [ __ ] do this puzzle now what
is that's a brilliant thing I want to
see treated his titties since I was 13
literally Michael is terrified of me
touching this item because he thinks the
box is pool and he doesn't want me to
ruin it so this is really cool fallout
vinyl collectible Oh
get scared Michael don't worry nothing
bad is gonna happen
Oh Brad I said it's gone are you happy
so the next what are these I don't know
what it is no I don't think it's for
kids you want to become you wanna make a
terminator cake that's terrifying
whoo I love this I love this pin I am a
big fan of pins this is a cool pin we
have BioShock Infinite I love that game
I am so excited what could this be a key
blank oh wait that was the key where's
the King oh oh it's like in the game oh
that's cool if you play the game you
know I know the reference you'd be like
oh that's that's the lootcrate value you
know so it's got the bird or the cage is
that the bird or the cage look right I
love you thank you for supplying me with
awesome items every month guys if you
haven't checked that alert or yet I
recommend that you do so not only
because it supports the show but I
really appreciate it thank you so much
check out loot crate go to loot crate
home slash pewds enter the code pewds
you guys know the drill
sponsor Eagle will hook you guys up
hurry up with the item it's a spa it's
as portable spa everyone it's a spa it
is a spa I bought this with real money I
need to relax you're so tense Felix
you're so tense feel it
Thank You Brad you know I'm a hard
worker say I'm a hard worker you're
really hard work on I know I work you
know I worked overtime at night why not
try why not have a spa tell them tell
them how humble I am and how much they
donate to charity you're so humble and
you I can't believe you don't have any
I'm not here to talk about my charity
work or all the time I spent helping out
other people and just being an overall
good person but you know what I think
I've earned a day off so let's blow up
the spa
get enough subs you can live the high
life that I've earned this all I worked
so hard
the real use of your life
[ __ ] you now what are you doing you're
ruining the champagne
No
it's thinking
who did this
[ __ ]
yeah don't found it yeah I'll get you
for this
Patera dactyl